they were trying to find Habits of
Highly Successful People and it seems as
though they were surprisingly fit one
that people have superiority complex
they believe they're better than others
and they believe that they deserve more
than everyone else does and that they
can accomplish big goals the second
thing they would identify is that they
had crippling insecurity and they feel
they'll never be enough and they'll
always be measured against the things
that they've achieved and they actually
suck and then the third piece which kind
of adds the beautiful like mix of this
is impulse control and so they're able
to control their actions and focus on a
single thing for an extended period of
time if you are the type of person who
has those traits then you are very
likely to be successful